so yeah I guess so we've been hearing a
lot about the quantum PCP tier I'm going
to talk about something different which
is the quantum PCP conjecture from I
don't know who called it a theorem so so
yeah so we've heard a lot so this was a
joke right I'm going to talk about the
same thing that we've heard about in
every single talk up to now so it's
unclear if I have there's anything new I
can say it's so so completely unclear
that I'm the best person to be saying
things about this so you know I guess
this hour will be devoted to sing again
what we've said but you know all in one
place so it might be helpful to put
everyone on the same page I mean it can
also be a discussion so feel free to
interrupt or raise the same arguments
and counter-arguments that we've heard
before again or raise new ones so so
here's the plan for the talks over a
significant part of the talk will be
devoted to just stating the conjecture
trying to make it precise and arguing
about whether this is the correct
statement of the PCP conjecture it's
what we want to be is it relevant if
it's relevant why you know in what
regime is it relevant to discuss the
parameters and then the two other parts
will be also in second part I'll talk
about some possible approaches so this
will sort of build a little bit upon
Lucas talk and try to see well okay
suppose we try to prove this thing now
or what can we do and when when where do
we run into trouble and then the last
part of the talk if I have time um I'll
discuss more serious obstructions to the
conjecture and the same kind that that
sure was already discussed in arm stock
so obstructions strong obstructions that
say well you know the conjecture might
be true but it cannot be true in that
region oh let's go that's the outline um
so it's let me start so one thing that
has not been done before so so I'll do
it here is is it and I think it's kind
of interesting is just try to remember
where this conjecture comes from you
know why you made this conjecture in the
first place why why is it made and that
might help us understand what the
meaning of it is so let me go over a
little bit of history for for all I know
so the we can go back to the statement
of the local Hamiltonian problem itself
so this even this I'm not too sure so
the citation I'm putting up is the book
by
ki Tov Shan and valley but then I've
heard this introduction of local
Hamiltonian attributed to kita if in a
lecture at Hebrew University in 99 and
then I saw in Zeb stock it was 97 so I
don't know if you know better um look at
that formulation wish right maybe you're
more qualified to say where it is local
Hamiltonian control I'm not sure whether
d consumer so it could well be 99 now
all I know it said it was it was
conceived on guitar conceived of it a
few days before he flew to the Hebrew
University okay to give a talk and he
wanted to have something interesting to
stop okay okay so then it's probably
that's probably ki Tov and it's probably
in 99 because the 99 I got from the
weight so it might be 99 um so we've
seen this problem a lot but I'll just
stay there again because maybe not
everyone was in every single talk so
what's the local Hammond so since all
right nobody said so it was introduced
as a generalization of classical
constraint satisfaction problems right
that was the motivation find an
interesting quantum generalization of
something that's interesting classically
like local system restarts and so here's
the statement arm you have local
hamiltonians HJ so each of these local
hamiltonians is a hermitian matrix or it
has sized e to the K by D to the K so
there's two important parameters d is
the dimension of each of the particles
for the whole talking thing of gay ports
too if you want but you know it could be
a little bit bigger usually we think of
it as a constant K is the locality it's
the number of q dates on which each of
the Hamiltonians act so these matrices
act on k particles of dimension d each
so they're d to the K by D to the K
matrices usually we tensor them with the
identity on the other qubits to make
them n to the K by sorry d to the N by D
to the n matrices and they have norm at
most wonderful it's same ok so that's
the input and the parameter that we're
interested in is the ground energy or
the minimum i can value of the local
hamiltonian so H here is just the sum of
the local hamiltonians so there's the
ground energy and then there's the
ground state which is the eigenvector
that's associated to the mainland
value lets the local hamiltonian and
what's the okay i'm sorry i have a
little picture these are your cue dates
arm and you can think of each
Hamiltonian H I on acting on a small
subset of the queue date so in that case
k is equal to three because each of the
local hamiltonians Oksana contributed
local Hamiltonian problem is the
following given an instance of this
problem and two parameters a and B that
are separated by an inverse polynomial
at least is the ground state energy of
the Hamiltonian at most a or is it
larger than be so that's how could I
have introduced the local Hamiltonian
problem we've seen this before I think
this is clear for everyone all right how
do we give you example is the kind of
trivial examples I try to do this quick
it doesn't really matter but just to
make it a little bit concrete one
example is your just remind you that
this local Hamiltonian problem contain
contains classical constraint
satisfaction problems so you can phrase
for instance Mac Scott as an instance of
this problem that case locality will be
two dimension will be too and the
constraints these hamiltonians they
enforce that cubits that are adjacent
should be assigned different values so
if you really want to see what the
matrix is it would look something like
this it's something that assigns the
score of 1 to the state 0 0 in a score
of 1 to the state 11 so when the values
sorry I did it the wrong way round it
should be the opposite of this no no
it's this because you want to minimize
the value so you score minus 14 when the
qubits are 0 1 or 10 right so this gives
you a score 1-1 when the values are
different and you're trying to minimize
the energy this is it same as finding
the largest possible cut this we can
generalize are you know so in
statistical physics you look at the
Ising model which you can think of as a
generalization of Mac Scott where you
allow weights on the edges not insisting
on this an example of a quantum
Hamiltonian that generalizes Mac Scott
is the Heisenberg model where again
locality k is two dimension D is too so
there are qubits but now the you have a
certain graph with edges there's weights
on the edges and the constraints instead
of simply seeing that the two qubits
should be assigned different values
they'll force the joint state of the two
qubits to lie in the ante
symmetric subspace so this is basically
saying that across every edge you wanted
the two qubits to be in a particular and
time will state that's the constraint
and we've shown recently that you know
even for a very simple such instance of
local Hamiltonian problem k is two
dimension is to hamiltonians they all
look like this the only thing that
varies is the graph in the weights then
this problem is Oh kill me hard but I'm
getting a little Headroom myself with
these examples so let's go back to the
on this right so so what kita Eve and
quarters showed is that if the locality
is five each constraints axel five
cubits and their cubits then this local
Hamiltonian problem is a QM a complete
so as two parts to showing clearly
completeness you have to check that the
problem is inside qma and then you have
to show a reduction from any qm a
complete problem to local Hamiltonian so
showing that this is inside qma r is
easy the witness will just be the ground
state of the local hamiltonian and then
the verification procedure will be where
you check you pick a constraint at
random and you implement a measurement
or that is going to have a success
probability that's proportional to the
energy of the state with respect to the
constraint not going to details it's
pretty straightforward the other side is
is very interesting arm showing that
arbitrary qm a complete problem for
instance or you know circuits out so
you're given a quantum circuit and you
want to decide does there exist a state
that is accepted by this circuit or does
they're not exist any state that's
accepted by the circuit or it does use
the basic um a complete problem and now
what you want to do is take your circuit
and construct a local Hamiltonian out of
it such that if the circuit had an
accepting input the local Hamiltonian
has low energy and if the circuit
rejected oil inputs then the Hamiltonian
does not have low energy all the states
or have energy above this threshold be
and that's non-trivial so you know this
is already done classically when you
prove the NP completeness of three sides
you take your circuit and you encode the
circuit in a certain way by basically
thinking of the circuit as a layered
thing that acts on the input and the
proof the proof the witness will be the
whole will sort of represent the whole
evolution of the circuit so for every
gate you'll have new variables etc
maybe a lot of you have seen this
quantum case this doesn't work so easily
because you can't copy the quantum
information you can't really deal with
the different quantum states at
different stages of the circus is the
big inside the cat I've had was to look
at the witness here will be a
superposition of the state of the
circuit at all possible time steps and
then he showed that um if this is how
you think about the witness then you can
verify so you can verify that a given
state is in this form is a soup arm just
by making local checks just by using
local habitant all right so this was the
initial result and then there were a lot
of improvements trying to you know get
keep qm a harness so the same hardness
but for simpler and simpler instances of
local Hamiltonians for instance getting
the locality down from five down to two
this was achieved by Kettle campaign
regev and then more recently there were
further results I think Daniel talked
about this in his talk already that try
to get cream a harness for physically
relevant systems so you start talking
about what the actual local Hamiltonians
look like what the interaction graph
looks like so this all you got interval
they showed qm a harness for a local
Hamiltonian problem where the
interactions are nearest neighbors on a
2d grid and then this was improved
further two systems that are
one-dimensional even systems that have
translation invariance so we're getting
very close to proving am a hardness for
systems that sort of physical irrelevant
for instance this Heisenberg model that
I had in the in the previous slide all
right so that's one of the local
Hamiltonian problem so now we're
interested in a particular version of
that problem so the quantum our quantum
this quantum PCP conjectures so I try to
trace back where this comes from where
is it first mentioned and what's a
little bit the history of the of the
problem so the first mention I could
find on the droid could find I guess I
don't know if this is the first but it's
in 2002 it's some lectures that do it
aronoff was giving at the Hebrew
University on quantum computing and that
the end of the lectures there's a whole
lot of open questions and the last open
question is this is exactly what's
written there there's no more no
explanation so there's a quantum analog
of the PCP theorem um cold so that
appears there
and then I don't know what happens
afterwards but further mention that you
can find is on a blog this is Scott Eyre
sins blog he had a an entry in 2006 so
he was a poster girl like you see at the
time and he calls it quantum PCP
manifesto and here's his statement of
the quantum PCP or conjecture um you can
read it i guess i'm going to give a
statement later which is equivalent to
what he's stating although one
interesting thing is that he's already
pointing to an interesting difference
between classical constraint
satisfaction problems and this quantum
constraint satisfaction problem local
hamiltonian which isn't in the classical
case you have all these constraints and
then you're trying to find an assignment
which satisfies the most possible number
of constraints and when you have an
assignment and constraint the constraint
is either satisfied or not satisfied in
a point in case you can see this here um
there's one more thing that happens
which is that the constraints there's
these Hamiltonians they have a certain
energy respect to the state they can be
a little bit satisfied or very satisfied
so for instance you can look at
assignments which satisfy all the
constraints a little bit or things like
that so that's why here's these two
parameters or epsilon delta here well i
stayed a equivalent version of the of
the conjecture soon um so this blog
entry he makes a few conjectures or
predictions that are interesting so
first are his 99% sure that the theorem
were well conjecture as I stated it for
my talk is a true okay so we don't know
19 a five percent sure that the proof
will be interesting um eighty-five
percent sure that oppose achievable in
the euro so in this was 2006 so um
seventy-five percent sure that the proof
will be very interesting and point one
percent sure that he can prove it so um
at least this has been verified but I
don't know not that he tried much I
don't know not that anyone else has been
able to prove it either so and okay
another interesting thing this is an
interesting blog post is is this strange
to go back to 2006 and there's some
comments and there's few comments
there's like a dozen comments and
they're all very pointed very
interesting comments very relevant now
in particular there's one comment I what
I wanted to show you I don't know look
how if you remember writing this comment
on
scotsblog it's interesting very good
comment and it's I'm going to get into
going to that comment lodging the talk
so you should focus on the last
paragraph and what Luca is pointing out
is that um you know here when we're
introducing this quantum PCP conjecture
we're saying well look I mean there's
constraint satisfaction problems and
there's the classical PCP theorem and
this has been so exciting why don't we
define a quantum version of it and then
study the quantum version right surely
it'll be exciting and look I is saying
you know you have to be careful because
it's not at all clear that the most
productive you know results theorems
conjectures in quantum information will
be obtained simply by taking things that
are known classically and saying well
let's make a quantum version of it um
and Paul that I could see up to that
point this is what was happening this
was the main motivation for the quantum
PCP oh this corner pcr manifesto and if
you look at the other comments in the
blog people are pointing out two things
that look I said that one of the
motivations for the classical piece p2m
what we already sort of knew that I mean
there was this quest for in approximate
honest of approximation results and this
motivated classical PCP and here it's
not clear that we have our such a quest
for quantum hardness of approximation
results so that does not motivate quite
a PCP so I don't spend some time in the
talkin in trying to motivate quantum PCP
on purely or quantum information
theoretic grounds because I think now we
have such grounds and it makes the
conjecture all the more interesting it
was interesting at the time it's it's
more interesting now um all right go
back to Scott so this is caught in his
blog post which is saying well okay why
haven't we sold this thing yet and he's
saying one of the reasons is that um no
one has stated it formally and it's true
I couldn't find a formal statement of
the of the conjecture beef until after
later but he's kind of dodging the
question I mean he's saying well you
know do not let's just not worry about
this right I'll quantum PCP theorem is
anything that's interesting in st
anything that's a robust version of the
of the local hamiltonian Quilliam a
completeness theorem that i showed you
before alright so the first there so the
first formal statement of the specific
injector you can find a wish this is the
first I could find so it's a paper by
arunabha rod Lando in buzzer Ronnie
where they give two equivalent
formulations of the conjecture which
are based on the two equivalent
formulations of the classical PCP
theorem that look I gave us so there's
one formulation which is based on the
concept of proof checking proof
verification so with the idea is that
you should be able to verify disk um a
witness the state by looking at only a
constant number of qubits and then
there's another formulation which they
are phrases a gap amplification problem
so the conjecture there would be that
there exists a procedure which amplifies
the gaps of these local hamiltonians you
start with a local Hamiltonian instance
that scream a complete has a promise gap
that's inverse polynomial and you want
to map it to another instance where the
promise gap now is a constant I'm going
to give a statement of the conjecture
which is neither of these tool on but
its equivalent so this is the local
Hamiltonian a definition of local
Hamiltonian we saw this before so here's
the statement we finally get to a
statement of the conjecture we've seen
it many times before but again so what
is what is the conjecture it's saying
that a particularly strong version of
the local Hamiltonian problem is qm a
hard so it's saying that there is two
threshold values a and B that are
separated by alpha this is a parameter
let's say think of alpha is a constant
now x m m is the total number of
constraints in the local hamiltonian
such an instance so k is the local EDD
is a dimension of the qubits it's came a
hard to distinguish between these two
cases it's exactly the same as before
are the only thing that's changed is
that now before what we were asking be
an aid to be separated by an inverse
polynomial and now I'm asking them to be
separated by a constant times the number
of constraints so it's a much stronger
promise all right so I haven't been
precise about the parameters and as far
as I know there's no precise statement
of the conjecture that Nathan it makes
any bets as to the parameter so I want
to spend some time discussing for which
parameters this could be for each
parameters this is true in which four
parameters it could be two we like to
put in so for instance now I haven't
said what alpha is so if alpha is 1 over
polynomial in N for large enough way no
meal then we know this is true this is
the
make a hardness without they mentioned
already no no let's not get into that
debate helm no no gap amplification is
gap it's it's it's this value right so
it's not the gap of the Hamiltonian yeah
sorry so um I don't know how you call
this um this is the only gap i'll be
talking about in this talk know how many
trillions will have gaps above the
ground state energy okay thanks okay so
let's stare a little bit at the at the
parameters so just because they're going
to come up this is the only parameters
that are going to come up but they'll
come up over and over again and I won't
say you know always but they are so n
will always be the number of particles
the number of Q dates M the number of
constraints and the number of
constraints the number of local terms
will be polynomial in n so I use n as my
input size parameter okay then there's
K&D so k is the locality the number of
particles on which each constraints are
acts and for instance if i allow k to be
equal to n and then the conjecture is
trivial i'm not saying anything
interesting because i can have our just
one term which is my original circuit
which acts on all the qubits so what
we'd like to have is we'd like to prove
this conjecture for constant K but it's
also interesting to think of super
constant K doesn't need to be constant
for instance poly logarithmic are
capable logarithmic in n.o is something
that could be interesting same thing
holds for d so d is the local dimension
we'd like to get this for the constant
for some d equals to write into just
cube it's the basic case but maybe you
know if it makes our life easier it
makes sense to look at slightly larger
by use of the local dimension and
finally maybe the most important
parameter is this a promise gap so right
let's call it to the promise gap instead
of just gap so as I mentioned a
conjecture is true for very small values
of alpha or we'd like to get it for
constant alpha but as far as I know
again it would be interesting to just
get alpha slightly above you know little
Oh
four of these kinds of values so um one
over poly log or one over even one of
our boo 10 or something like this
depending exactly how you call you
define it last what is the power what is
the best part yeah I don't know maybe
Daniel knows he said something the other
day but I'm not sure one over N squared
or n cubed and cube do you think what's
L OIC so and then yeah M cubed yes oh
I'm not sure because when you translate
the gates to the local Hamiltonian you
get more Hamiltonian terms in just the
number of gates because there's a lot
there's the clock and there's a lot of
stuff so okay I don't know oh just I
think there is a slightly better
construction by daniela guitar and
forgot another one sorry yeah very
meisel where it's instead of having the
number of gates it's the depth of the
circuit so and then it's the depth of
the circuit I think squared right okay
we don't really know let's let's take
this for later it's there's maybe some
best result but I don't know what it is
and it's at least one over N squared it
say I don't know so I allowing them to
grow it it's barely looked at football I
know so people really focused on k you
know up to five or something and dee dee
can grow to like 10 or something like
this but Tom so as far as I know no one
has really seriously investigated what
you could say as soon as you allow them
or you start from the other side ride
you look at what if K is root and can
you say anything your stem from but
there would be sort of natural regarding
police or things to look the other okay
for us too so for to drive you know it's
for you know Mia yeah right so which is
not yeah so you can approach it by below
right and I think 22 is maybe the only
case worried so I was going to mention a
few of these things in the next line so
oh it's not forgiven if a single case
with AMD or to the prophecy be np-hard
in this sense of the desert gap between
competing since office yes um yes so we
know that it cannot be cured ready 22 so
this this this for two and two even if
even if even if alpha 0 is he
I am Not sure oh I'm not sure let me see
a few results I know and then this one
in this one I'm not I'm not sure it's
okay when is it true is there's there's
very few cases where we know that it's
true i mean we do know it's true if i
get rid of km a hard and put NP hard
there look how discuss that and we also
know it's true if alpha is allowed to be
in verse polynomial so we've been over
that before and in that case if you are
thought to be so small it's true with
very strong parameters so i'm stating
some of these there okay what are some
limits that we know and i'll get back to
some of these limits to towards the end
of the talk if we have time so i can
mention a few already okay one case
that's been looking at is if you
restrict the Hamiltonians to commute
pairwise commute this interesting
restriction because it makes the problem
harder to work with but it doesn't make
it trivial at all oh it doesn't it
doesn't reduce it to the classical case
but we do know that if you force the
Hamiltonians to commute and if the
locality is too so the constraints are
from two particles or it's three but
then you have to restore the dimension
to at most three or if the constraint
graph has some good expansion properties
then the problem is in NP and we also
know i guess i am talked about this
yesterday that if locality is too and
the constraint graph is a larger of the
goonies arm here i am i messing up the
was it d squared if yes down just e
squared ok so i guess there's a note
version of the result i can never keep
up um so into constraint graph as to
larger degree then the conjecture is
pulse for constant alcohol all right
that's I think basically the extent of
what we know about the conjecture so
I'll talk about things we don't know and
maybe there
later but yes which one oh I was here
that they're small said expand the
results yeah I was going to talk about
in work well I'm sorry i just wanna say
it's only for very small steps yes so
it's actually the conference I said so
yeah I'd agree one okay okay yeah I'm
not going to get into details of this i
think i think we won't have time but
there's this essentially for those who
are interested there's two sets of
results that focus on how the graph the
constraint graph that maps you know
where the couch which cubits to
constraints act on what are limitations
on the kind of graphs that you could use
does this paper that i am told us about
yesterday and this paper by our own
often and a doctor good places to look
at it somehow we do need expansion but
right but very small said expansion is
not good and so we get to that later or
so i was going to get to it later it's a
point yeah um it's clear that you need
some expansion because otherwise you can
chop up the graph into small pieces
right so maybe we should have that disc
aside in the intuition low for the other
side so i don't give some in his talk
there's infusion related to monogamy say
I mean that's intuition for the degree
like so the thing is on right so here
we're treading the border between the
problem between qma hard or np-hard what
this is saying is that your graph needs
to be an expander in all cases because
if it's not an expander basically you
need to have very good connectivity
properties because if it doesn't then
you can solve the problem just by
chopping the graph into small pieces
solving it into each of the small pieces
by some stupid brute force algorithm and
then just putting these pieces together
and if you've been able to separate the
graph into small pieces by only cutting
there's only a few edges so there's only
a few constraints that you're ignoring
by doing this chopping then just putting
the small pieces together will give you
a good solution like it'll have energy
which is not minimal will be a little
bit above minimal and here we are
allowing you know large margin we're
allowing to screw up a constant fraction
of the constraints so if you can
disconnect the graph in small pieces by
cutting constant fraction of edges this
is not good so he needs to have this
kind of expansion
at least these results are saying if it
has two good expansion or actually I'm
not quite sure it's good to be saying if
it has two good expansion because
because you're right that this is a kind
of very specific form of expansion and
the result here is mostly about the
degree so these results are mostly
saying that the degree couldn't be too
large and here it's because if the
degree is too large then because of
intuition related to monogamy the ground
state will actually be close to a tensor
product state in a tensor product state
you can represent classically using
point 0 many many bits so that puts the
problem in NP if I could push you really
so there's a somewhat similar story
install the node in the UGC world okay
true but different yes there you know
strong expanders be yeah it'll be hard
but the story seems different because
there it's genuinely expansion and not
degrade oh no I mean I cannot say if you
look at the max cut costs raise a
special problem passing inside if the
graph has put expansion it was case then
you can get a sub exponential green form
ax cut but what you said grab the
graphing to pieces and so locally but so
the graph needs at least a kind of
expansion to prevent kenichi algorithm
from existing in hard distances but that
Vista graph has good expansion property
so even more small cell expansion
properties then semi definite programs
do very well so a so hard distance is
even in a classical case or those that
are somewhat expanding but not great
expanding and so they are decent a
senior
I'm yeah I'm aware of that I think the
question is also are the reasons that
the due date so for instance you pointed
the lower reason was the same the upper
reason is that as dps do well can this
be related to what I just said for why
these instances would be easy in the
quantum case which is this monogamy um
and I'm not sure they can because here
I'm not saying the instances these are
not cases where it's easy it's cases
where the problem is in NP but it could
still be and be hard so but let me I
Ramez Garcia people we also show a cpu
well on the quantum case but when you go
when you not only have high degree but
also the same small set expansion
properties so maybe there's questions um
would be okay I think this is an
interesting discussion is also equipped
with this so let's go on and then maybe
we have time to get back to it and
otherwise be it's a long lunch break
week and it's interesting question so um
before going into probing like how you'd
prove the conjecture further
obstructions then these ones I wanted to
do what I renounce originally which is
try to motivate this conjecture from a
physical point of view or try to see if
it makes sense um so because there's a
few sort of things that are in the
statement here that might seem arbitrary
or it's not clear why we're making these
choices whether the knife thing is what
why do we look at the minimal energy or
the ground state um more interesting
thing is why why are we really
interested in proving qma arnasay you
know we have NP hardness already isn't
that hard enough I mean what's the
difference between hard and very hard
okay smaller smaller question is why do
we are really want K&D to be constants
to this easy question get a harder
question why do we want this constant
gap alpha with the significance
that all right aren't we happy with I
mean what's what's this cup saying
anything so and the answer hopefully is
related to the physical motivation for
the conjecture so I'll go I try to not
spend too much time on this but Wendell
a bit of time over all of these four
questions give you some motivation
there's some physicists in the audience
I hope there is not okay good especially
now has a wide why the energy I you know
I I don't know it seems to me that
energy is just a fundamental quantity
that you can associate to most physical
or old physical systems and it kind of
acts as a representative represents it's
a simple thing that you'd want to know
about any system that you can measure in
the lab depending on the system there's
many different ways you could measure
the energy and it just serves as a proxy
for you know interesting property of my
system or basic property of my system so
why the minimal energy arm well that's
the energy of the ground state so why
the ground state so there's been a lot
of discussion already about this I want
to just make the discussion tiny bit
more precise so one thing that we know
is that when you have this local
Hamiltonian would describe the
constraints on your system and the
system is at a certain temperature then
the equilibrium state is given by this
Gibbs Boltzmann distribution so the
state will be this is the density matrix
of the state and it'll be proportional
to exponential in line so this is just a
constant divided by temperature times
the Hamiltonian so this means that your
state will be such that eigen states of
the Hamiltonian that have a certain
eigenvalue or e and the eigenvalue has
probability of rising at a certain
temperature that is proportional to this
thing here so if you look at the plot of
this function so this is the that
function for different temperatures and
as the temperature gets smaller the
probability function goes you know to
the left and it becomes more pointed
which means that as the temperature goes
to zero on this stationary distribution
the equilibrium of your system this
becomes concentrated on again states of
the Hamiltonian which have small energy
ok so the sort of conclusion of this is
that what's the ground state it's the
steady state to the state of equilibrium
of your system when the temperature is 0
the way are we interested in zero
temperature in father I know you know
most systems are not at zero temperature
but the systems that you can work with
in the lab tend to have zero temperature
that's when their stables so that's when
you can do measurements experiments you
can control the properties of the
material so it's kind of relevant to be
looking at the most stable states of
your system these are those that you can
control all the best but they're not
necessarily are the most relevant either
for instance on you know it's not
necessarily the case and we talked about
this a little bit more later that these
states exist so you can try to cool down
your system make it reach the ground
state but it might not happen you might
not be able to get a system that's
that's stable so right so the conclusion
of this is that ground state who kind of
makes sense with its it's also a little
bit arbitrary I mean there's many other
states that are interesting here we
focus on the ground state because we
have to start somewhere and it seems
like it's the thing that though you can
understand it that's all that's
interesting
but what's the relationship between the
temperature which I understand is some
average quantity it's an average
and
no so the temperature is just the
temperature you measure using the thermo
meter and the energy is all kinds of
things like kinetic energy potential
energy of chemical discussion should I I
just looked at this formal and I want a
sudden got them like that so we get back
so I looked at this e to the whatever
may be divided by T times eh and so
that's actually does not that's you and
you said that the density matrix but
that's not a one-dimensional dancing I
mean there's not a rank one density
matrix no no it's great it is actually
it is a mixture for yours states may our
sense is that the temperature T this is
the mixture and that's I think the
success area lightining for me that that
it is not a single I can state but it is
a certain mixture and if you change the
P then it's just going to be a
difference yeah so that's the point of
this picture as T goes to 0 your mixture
it becomes more and more concentrated on
just a single point which is the ground
state
is just my basic knowledge is
temperatures are the average velocity of
the particles in your system that's
yellow to speciality that's fine for gas
particles in the room or something
somewhat more generally the temperature
expresses the rate of change of the
entropy with respect to energy so if you
were to put a little more energy into
the system how many more states could
the system occupy that rate of change is
expressed by the difference
the KND parameters I'm not going to
spend time on these it's natural to
require them to be constants at least
the locality because these are
Hamiltonians the number of qubits on
which they act on these Hamiltonians are
modeling forces that act on the system
and I think Daniel or this we talked
about this before um you know the models
of physics that we have talked about to
local or three local interactions we
don't we don't typically have
interactions that involve too many
particles these I mean the laws of
physics are like this right they did
they're basically be attraction or
repulsion forces between neighboring
electrons or things like that um the
dimension you could argue a little bit
about it because depending on your
system how it's modeled you could think
of a system that has continuous degrees
of freedom in which case you could be
asking well you know what if I allow d
to go to infinity um but D here is also
a measure of you know how complex these
constraints can be so H I acts on these
let's say k equals 2 so it acts on these
two particles each of which has
dimension D if I allowed you to be very
large I'm allowing my H items to be very
very complex and this is kind of putting
the complexity in the place I don't want
it to be so I think it's natural to
require d to be your constant or
something that grows slowly maybe
there's other parameters that we are not
part of the conjecture but that would
make sense physically which is that you
know typically these hamiltonians which
describe the constraints on your system
they tend to be not only local in the
sense that each they act on a constant
number of particles at the time but also
they only act on neighboring particles
right and its neighboring in the sense
that your particles are arranged maybe
on the 2d or on the 3d lattice another
thing that tends to happen is that each
of these local terms here should be the
same essentially so there should be some
translation invariance before for
instance if H is supposed to model a
repulsive force this repulsive force is
the same in between any two pair of
electrons whether they're here or there
over there this is something that's not
required as part of the conjecture in
the way that I stated it but it's it's a
desirable property that
H is where would all be the same or very
close to being the same up to maybe some
some weights and in terms of km a
hardness so if I allow the gap to be
small then in recent years even you know
this year last year does results on this
and I mentioned this already they come
close to achieving kill a harness for
these kinds of physically relevant
systems all right more interesting
question so why are we interested in
showing qma harness instead of
np-hardness what's the physical
relevance of making a statement the
local Hamiltonian problem is qm a hard
for constant gaps instead of just being
NP hard for constant gaps which is
something that we know already from the
pcp theorem so difference between the
two is that were saying that well the
problem is not in NP right that's one
way to think I mean if we assume qma is
different from NP or we even saying that
okay the problem is not in QC ma so this
is saying that um you there is no
classical witness right that's what kind
of I think morally what we want to say
when we're sinking a harness and not
beyond NP harness we're saying that
there is no classical witness there is a
quantum witness for my system having low
energy but low classical witness and
what this is saying is that if there is
no classical witness for the fact that
my Hamiltonian has a very low energy it
means a few things I mean first it means
that there is no classical witness for
the fact that the ground state has low
energy in particular there is no
efficient classical description of the
ground state that lets me compute its
energy from it so for instance the
ground state cannot be a tensor product
state if it was I would have a classical
description so a month it must have a
high enough entanglement high enough
entanglement oh okay another thing for
instance is that the ground state cannot
be generated by actually poly sighs this
is wrong I should have written by a log
depth or circuit because if the GaN
state could be generated from a product
state by a small depth circuit I could
give that circuit as my classical
witness and you can verify that this
circuit would let you compute the energy
in polynomial time so that's a form of
saying this going back
to arms question am I have a suggestion
I was going to get back to this later
but I don't know so in arm stock he said
he was saying the only obstructions we
have to queue PCP are cases where we can
say that the ground state is well
approximated in some sense by a tensor
product state and then you are saying
what we want to go beyond that and think
of cases where we derive obstructions by
saying well the ground state is maybe
not close to a tensor product state but
it's close to something that's slightly
untangled and then we have this whole
wealth of entanglement measures to
choose from and we don't quite know how
to measure slightly untangled so that's
a very natural way to measure slightly
entangled in terms of the QP CP
conjecture we can say that the state is
a little bit untangled if you can
generate it from a tensor product state
via a low depth circuit so that would be
ya know so that would give you classical
witness but it's not clear you would be
able to compute the energy because the
polynomial size circuit can generate a
lot of entanglement so you wanted to be
able to contract the tensile load
voltage show that it's QC ma it's in QC
oh yeah qca so that probably means that
it's not very hard right no oh that's it
yes yes sorry yes okay okay yes okay um
another point here is that right so I
guess this relates to your question
which is to say um you know in trying to
put the problem in NP it's not clear
what the classical witness for the state
should be so for instance you can think
of a two-dimensional state that would
have a two-dimensional tensor network
representation so that's something that
I can specify efficiently classically
but doesn't allow me or to compute the
energy so it could be that the
conjecture is true that ground states
have efficient classical descriptions
but you can't efficiently compute the
energy or verify that the energy is low
from these descriptions this is a type
of description for which I don't know if
you can compute the the energy
another interesting point also is that
if you try to put the problem in NP it's
not clear that the witness needs to be a
representation of the ground state
itself it needs to be something that
convinces you that the energy is low and
we have one example of this um that we
came up with I mean it is very simple
but in the survey with food or eat any
ties so is to show that qma so the local
Hamiltonian problem has exponential
sighs classical witnesses so if you try
to prove the put the problem in NP you
want to play normal size description of
your state or point normal-sized witness
what we can show is that there's a
exponential size witness um but that you
can verify just by making a constant
number of queries so this is saying that
there's a way to encode your quantum
state into exponentially many bits which
is so far trivial because you can just
write all the coefficients but this
encoding has the property that you can
evaluate the or verify that this state
has low energy with respect to your
Hamiltonian just by looking at a
constant number of entries to a constant
number of coefficients the fact that
this kind of proof exists actually
follows from very non things from the
fact that q mas in PHP space is equal to
IP etc it follows from the literature
but just writing it explicitly is
interesting and this proof has a
property that it does not encode the
state itself it in quotes properties of
the Hamiltonian or directly and just by
looking at the witness you can make the
verification about having any idea of
what the state is although it just means
that yummy I mean the text my exercise
class cigar proof it means
and I it's MX all right then did not
really know that yes of course yes yes
so um so it says a little bit more
because you can you can verify it
locally but but of course we know that
NX is equal to I don't know MIP so you
can verify if you know the PCPD I'm so
yes we knew this yeah um yes I'm not
claiming it as a result sorry I was just
the result is just to sort of instead of
saying what you said and then having to
figure out what is the proof by doing a
lot of reductions and having all kind of
error correcting codes and all kinds of
things we have just there like one
paragraph proof which says exactly what
is this proof looking like and relating
it to the local Hamiltonian so in a very
natural proof so but there's nothing new
oh yeah it's an exercise you can do it
this interesting exercise is what I
wanted to say okay one last thing is why
do we want a constant gap where is that
relevant so this brings us back to this
gift distribution so the reason the
constant gap is is going to be relevant
is so that you make statements not only
about the ground state but about states
that are above the ground States about
excited state so this gets the
distribution arm if you look at it this
density matrix here is a distribution on
I ghen states of the Hamiltonian and
it's a distribution which is going to be
concentrated on states that have energy
that go up to n times temperature over k
be right because above this then the
probability becomes exponentially small
so even though there's exponentially
many states that the contribution to the
total probability mass will be very
small so now the PCP conjecture is
saying that it's hard to make the
difference between the ground state
energy being something and the ground
state energy being alpha times M or
and let's think of them as being the
same above that so it's not only saying
that there is not the classical witness
for the ground state it's saying that
you know if your energy is very low but
the problem is not in NP there's not a
classical witness for any state that has
energy the bottom the a parameter and
also very far above up to until you
reach be so there is no windows for any
of these states any of the states that
have energy between a and a plus the gap
roughly and because the gap is alpha and
you're saying that there is no classical
witness for all the states that show up
in this distribution as long as the
temperature is that most boltzmann
constant or something times are your gap
so this is what it's saying not only the
ground state must have high entanglement
but all states that have low energy must
have high untimely because otherwise
they could also be fine witnesses you
don't need to probably the ground state
as a witness you need to provide
anything that has energy less than the B
parameter and that's fine that's because
of the promise it's not to certify the
ground state energy is small and these
are the states because of this formula
here these are the states that arise at
temperatures that go up to constant
temperature so these are much more sort
of realistic temperatures so that's one
very strong statement or quantum PCP is
making not only the ground state is very
entangled which is something we might
believe but also that many states that
exist at higher temperatures also this
should also be highly entangled
otherwise we could give them as
witnesses and this it depends where you
talked about it might run to some
counter intuition we physicists might
say that no but look I mean that high
temperature or high temperature I mean
not Leslie that high right could be 10
Kelvin or 100 Kelvin or something like
this but um things become much more
disordered like the system becomes more
complicated and so clear whether you can
have entanglement at that temperature
it's one of the things that make quantum
computers hard to construct right you
have to make these fridges to keep
things stable to control your
entitlement
these states are difficult to construct
which states sorry they want to come
from these a political quantum computers
oh yes yes yes four states then of
course right not be the Q&A yeah right
so this would say that it is possible
they these must put in that there are
states that stay found at very high
temperature but there's a physically
unrealizable it was the complexity of
being right exactly so that's kind of
the that's the tension or between the
conjecture because on the one hand we're
saying there's physics that there's
things that exist that we can control in
the lab that you know and surely this
cannot be cure me hard because we can
construct them and manipulate them and
they existed and they've been built in
you know a few years or a few million
years or whatever it since the earth
exists so these cannot be cured me hard
right and on the other hand we're having
this conjecture and we're trying to say
look these models wheel systems because
it's a local Hamiltonian because etc and
I'm going to try to prove that its cure
me hard and there's this tension between
the two and so I guess parts of the
conjecture yeah these are systems which
right right so that's coops that's this
thing here you know the only possibility
there's also sort of the ice nine
possibility so what no ice nine is
something because they have one copy of
it you can create any more cheaply first
copy is hard to create so this is also
within you know this is compatible with
with quantum with what a PCP being true
so it's like baby
the advice version oh yeah but how did
you create the first stage well maybe
just for doing you're busy yeah that's a
good idea but I'm just saying that it's
you know there's a lot of rumors it may
be actually just to clarify your little
warning after their entitlement not
persisting at room temperatures now
we're talking about a particular
distribution is not quite sure so when
we talk about the gift stay you mean
even this one doesn't exist or that
doesn't necessarily which it is true in
a way the gift is the equilibrium state
but you might not be in equilibrium yeah
it's quite different OHI or at least I'm
not seeing the equivalence between sort
of you know proofs of the existence of a
single state below some below some you
know threshold energy versus whatever
physicists intuition is about it tackle
Italy you know give states me yeah yeah
yeah i agree i don't really know you
you're right also this is a mixture over
many states and it could be that each of
these states individually has high
entanglement but when you have the
mixture you don't see any of it
to say that
but I mean you can write I mean you can
have mixtures of very entangled things
that have no entanglement right-click
the totally mixed state is mixture of
everything sore but it has no one okay
okay okay so good one less roadblock no
worries we have a lot of others
yes I think what you're saying maybe is
is that here we're really studying
worst-case complexity so even if the
conjecture was true it would be saying
that there is a Hamiltonian in this
particular class that has these
properties of having a lien tuc but of
course it might not be the Amal tonian
that the rice is so oh but that's a
little bit of the work that's done I
mean it's always still work worst case
but in the QM a harness results that I
mentioned before so that have that don't
have this promise on the gap this is
what people are trying to do when
they're saying okay we're trying to show
clearly harness for to local systems on
the grid or translation invariant and so
you put more and more constraints to try
to get closer and closer to the kind of
systems that are relevant but even then
right it's a worst-case thing and it
might not be the one that that's in your
lab before the key any hardness results
the intuition was right that's true
right right yeah that's a good point i
mean i guess so same thing with this so
with this right i mean there's a lot of
intuition in physics as to how systems
behave and maybe here we're just trying
to sort of push that intuition around
and see where it extends right i think
this is relevant also and these are the
algorithm that Zeph told us about this
one-dimensional algorithm or enamel time
algorithm that relies on the on the
existence of a spectral gap for the
hamiltonian so in this kind of situation
there might be some intuitions with
physics intuition that says well let
Goomer schwoz same 1d systems are easy
okay then we'd be asking what you mean
by 1d system what's the property of 1d
system and you saying you say well it's
a 1d system the constraints are in one
dimension
and then people work and then they come
up with a creamy hardness result for
what you were saying and then you say
well how come you have a cure my
hardness result and you're telling me
they're there easy then we have to look
at it a little bit more and then you
realize ah but you know all the systems
that actually arise in my lab have a
spectral gap maybe that was the reason
why it was easy not Nestle one deer was
a spectral gut and then we'd work on the
other side or is that would work on the
other side and say well yeah okay no you
tell me spectral gap now I have an
algorithm so so you're yeah so it's also
kind of a way to sort of alert what are
the important properties complexity
point of it so are you talking about
positive instances of a negative
instances because so when we are
discussing is entangled ground state or
are we talking about those positive
instances are 0 positive instances
positive but I mean a witness for a
positive instance to have a witness for
positive instance needs to be something
that convinces me that there is some
state that has kind of low energy right
so these are these are the instances I
think so most of you not another
question special
oh yeah i mean right correct okay yeah
right yeah yeah yeah by definition
so we're done with part one and thumbs
up so maybe I'll still two minutes try
to say now you know there was a
discussion of approaches based on on
what hookah told us two different proofs
of classical PCP theorem you know we
have these proofs why don't we try to
adapt them and see what goes wrong so I
had the sort of things that go wrong in
both of these proofs but maybe I just
say one thing that goes wrong and then
you know then we should but that will be
already five minutes and if there's
questions yeah the afternoon also is
very strict so but but five minutes is
okay or I could also just okay so I just
do one swell two sides the first slide
is a scotch telling us what's the way to
go so back back to his blog um he's
saying exactly what I just said right
now right if you want to prove the
quantum PCP theorem then just look at
the classical proofs and you know these
involved a lot of steps they recorded a
lot of work left let's get inspiration
from now from these steps and he's also
already pointing us to the difficulties
so he said so at the time do you it's
proof was very new waiting so people
were very excited by hit and he spent
one day studying it so Scott is Scott is
fast but but in one day he already found
a lot of obstructions so violations of
no cloning theorem so this um which is
not something I'm going to get into win
by one remaining slide so home I guess
so let's see this one are so the
classical the original proof of the PCP
theorem Luca mentioned involves a lot of
work using error correcting codes and
the error-correcting codes that go into
the proof have there's different types
of them they have two important
properties one is that they're locally
decodable or in the other is that
they're locally testable um I'm going to
focus on just this one property so local
decode ability of a code of an error
correcting code means that you know you
encode your word into a code word
it has the property that if you just
want to recover not the whole original
word for just a single chord in it you
can do this by reading few bits of the
encoding I put poly log here but ideally
it's it's better than that it's just a
constant phone number of bits of the
encoding these play an important role
because they let you sort of recover
information about the original
assignment just by making a few queries
or to the proof one of the natural
things to do in trying to prove this
quantum PCP is try to see if we can come
up with quantum locally decodable codes
there's there's a rich theory of quantum
error correcting codes definitely and
we'll hear about that later so it makes
sense to look into that and try to get
this property I'm not quite telling you
why we want this property but but we're
out of time I just want one slide to
argue that we cannot have such a thing
in the quantum regime not at all oh
right so let's let's see why right arm
so suppose we had a quantum error
correcting code it encodes a you know a
bunch of both of qubits X here is or
just the basis States classical string
and X bar is the encoding so it is just
high encoded on my state and suppose
that this code has a distance at most K
which means that any kind of error that
I make that acts on k qubits at most I
can correct in a certain way suppose
this code was locally decodable so
suppose I have some procedure on di so
it depends on I this is the coordinate I
want to recover such that when i run
this procedure on the encoded word and
this some ancilla i can recover the I
can you know decode this this coordinate
here all right without this without
destroying the code word this is where
the problem is going to arise so you
don't want presumably you don't want to
destroy it because this is your witness
um and you might be making more than one
query so this is a sorry
yeah you're right yeah the way I think
you saw right away what it is a bit
silly because it implies cloning if you
so you know this X could be a classical
string in which case it doesn't imply
cloning but you're right so my car to
destroy so you know in a quantum acp
theorem you you start with some from the
option you can make as many copies of
anything at that you want yes they were
procedure you have and then each time
you make a query you make it a different
copy here so it's fine to destroy it
you're saying ok so i guess my slide is
only going to argue that that quantum
locally decodable codes much much much
much sorry must destroy the whole code
word or in order to gain to recover just
a little bit of information that's a
good point what do you want
self-consistency right even within each
copy I mean what if what if the
adversary makes a different kind of
educational tests I see but that's
that's too many queries
could you ask for just some part of the
thing to be that you can't recover mean
isn't it reasonable to say something
like you've got some piece of the code
word laughing you can use with that yeah
I guess so so you could yeah so maybe
this is a week limitation I'm giving to
you so it's in the section of approaches
not in the section of obstructions so
it's just uh it's just okay I guess it's
just one thing you need to keep in mind
and there's probably ways to get around
it but at least this is something that
would be straightforward classically and
it's not in the indoor in the quantum
case let's put it to that then lindley
okay so then I just wrote why here
because if you could do this so
coherently then you could start from the
encoding of a superposition so here I
encoded the superposition of two inputs
one in which the ID beta 0 and the other
in which the it--but is one and so when
I run the local decoding in
superposition was supposed to be a
unitary to quantum procedure then this
decodes a 0 in this decode the one and
if I throw these bits that I just
decoded away what I end up is with a
mixture of my two original code words
instead of a superposition so what we
have here is that we have this procedure
the decoder and the decoder is a
procedure which is local so it acts on
that most K cubits by by running it and
then discarding the outcome of the
procedure I've destroyed the original
superposition that I had is a simple
superposition of two states so there's a
contradiction with the distance of the
code or being less than K distance of
the code being less than K mean means
that you should stay you know it should
be possible to correct this and here I
screwed up the superposition so I'm not
able to recover my original words from
from this this is irrevocably lost I
agree it so it's a maybe I shouldn't
have written this in red it's all
let's ignore those okay so that was just
one thing there's also obstructions more
seriously research to obstructions on
local testability that I'm not getting
into and there's one sorry yes so I'm
stopping right now um there's also work
in extending ear it's proof the gap
amplification proof and there is also a
babe i mentioned others and there's also
obstructions there and i will stop at
minus ten minutes okay fine okay